the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video well my
friends in this new video i have some
very exciting news regarding hbo's game
of thrones successor show house of the
dragon
now for those of you who do watch a lot
of my videos you most likely already
heard me discuss this back in february
in one of my older videos i showed you
an interview given by casey bloys who is
one of the executives over at hbo in
that interview he was asked whether or
not house of the dragon would be getting
a second season at that time he said
typically speaking i like to take an
approach where we will talk about what a
second season might look like and talk
about scripts we tend to like to see how
a show does first that said if i were a
betting man i'd say there is a good shot
that house of the dragon will get a
second season now with that being said
that wasn't necessarily confirming this
would actually happen in most cases they
will want to see how well the ratings do
as well as how it is received by not
only the fans but the critics as well so
although it is a little early to know if
house of the dragon will be getting a
second season information is already
starting to leak from inside hbo and
this brings me to the news i will be
discussing today according to a source
from rodanian intelligence house of the
dragon's second season is already
seemingly renewed at hbo they are saying
the much anticipated game of thrones
successor show house of the dragon is
finally airing in only a few months
after rapping filming earlier this year
now with all the work still to be
conducted until august it doesn't mean
writing work for the second season can
already begin
in fact that's exactly how game of
thrones would operate each next season
was already being written before the
current one was released we've been
informed by our sources that writing for
house of the dragon's second season has
indeed begun and that suggests hbo
already quietly renewed the new series
albeit without an announcement at this
time the official announcement of the
renewal should normally come closer to
either the season one premiere or the
finale as networks usually do whichever
way it went down behind the scenes of
hbo it's good to know that house of the
dragon's second season was given the
green light that said no series is ever
guaranteed from avoiding a sudden
cancellation however judging by the way
things look this most likely won't
happen and everything will be fine now
with all of that in mind you still have
to remember one thing this is not an
official announcement by hbo or george
rr martin as of right now this is only
according to certain sources so make
sure you still take it with a grain of
salt i myself do believe this news is
accurate given the fact that hbo's
executive already hinted at this all the
way back in february not only that but
this website has been accurate about a
lot of other things they have released
before now none of us will know how good
house of the dragon's first season will
be until we actually see it for
ourselves but based on what i've seen in
the trailer so far my guess is it will
be really damn good
i have a feeling we will be seeing house
of the dragon for many more seasons to
come let me know how all of you feel
about this down below how many seasons
of house of the dragon do you think hbo
will release
leave me some of your thoughts about
this new information as always i want to
thank everyone for watching this short
update video i hope all of you have a
great day
[Music]
foreign